JOHN LURIE: Once...
Once...
Once upon a time,
there was somethin'.
Oh, I'm not sure if I can
remember this, how it goes.
Once upon a time,
there was something really--
It was quite beautiful.
It was delightful.
Yeah, just imagine
something delightful.
Once upon a time,
there was something delightful.
Okay, I'm okay with this.
Hope you're okay with this.
♪ (MELLOW MUSIC PLAYING) ♪
You know, I don't know why
they gave me my own show
'cause I'm a mess.
(CHUCKLES) Really.
The world is getting to me
lately.
I really thought by this point,
the human beings
would be doing better.
So I'm going through
a grim period.
Clams, clams, clams...
with tartar sauce.
Mm.
FLEA: John!
JOHN: The phone rings,
and it's Flea.
John!
I can't even cheer
my own self up.
-John!
-Hey!
So I'm gonna have him
on the show.
John.
Uh, how you doin'?
(MUMBLES) I'm gonna lie down.
JOHN: This show
is a variety show.
But all these complicated plots
are introduced.
They found us.
They're coming!
(CELL DOOR SLAMS SHUT)
FLEA: That looks good.
JOHN: Yeah?
Really good.
JOHN: Wow.
That is really something.
I promise you,
the stories I tell on here,
they're all true.
Except for the stories,
of course,
that are obviously not true.
-Right, Nesrin?
-That is right, John.
(CHUCKLES)
JOHN: I mean,
the odds were against me.
I survived some stuff
in this life,
and I'm proud
that I'm still here.
And I put beautiful things
into this world.
And I hope to keep doing that.
(LAUGHTER)
And it's like, "Okay."
And then I came back
a little bit on the humans.
I'll give them another chance.
♪ (VOCALIZED BEATS) ♪